this is not in okay this is a weight
Under and Over drill okay so all I have
to do is get my weight on your
elbow there is a certain Arc of motion
that that elbow
takes there is a certain Arc of motion
that my ADI
[Music]
takes and I'm going to have that elbow
go underneath and there's another
certain Arc of motion that my hand hand
takes and I mix all those arcs so they
all land at the same time over the
elbow so I'm not going
to do a push
pull see one AR's already done then come
here so if you pay attention the arm Arc
is moving
forward then I finish my leg and then I
try to do
now one
heavy
Arc go
[Music]
that
all
try again there's a I'm just doing a
timing
drill but you going to do the right you
can do the right
timing but you're using different
engines okay so I want to keep my
structure
boom so you can't push
push
boom can't push push you can't push okay
down so I'm
in this rear posterior chain activation
position just like I was doing a back
squat don't lower your
center it's not Maring gravity oh
different rear posterior
chair rear
chain
re posterior
CH okay that's go